that king advanced earlier is because
white's bishop actually got trapped
which which of course i did by the black
king which of course i did you know
completely missed out
i mean i think the position was very bad
wasn't it it's very bad yeah just maybe
with best player you could have found
some tricks or some way to save it but
uh not easy and magnus now it's a pawn
race both sides have pawns on this left
side of the board but the black knight
the key is it can drop back to help and
there we go it's gonna try and sacrifice
itself for white sea pawn and then
black's b-pawn is gonna promote and win
the game black is going to end up with a
new queen and look at the evaluation bar
plus
nearly plus 16. yeah
yes yeah the big problem also is that
the black king can take a step backwards
and also cover some squares as well yeah
look at that
and oh it's over
resigns and that means he doesn't only
lose the game he loses the match
against magnus crossing a fantastic
start for the world champion a win in
its match against